my name is Morgan Medlin and I'm 20
years old
someone were to think that I can't win
because I'm So Young that all I have to
say to them is just watch me
I'm Travis Wertz I own a company that
manufactures accessories and tools for
knife makers and I made my first real
knife when I was 12.
Morgan Travis congratulations you're
both moving on to the final round now
we're sending you home to forge an
iconic blade
thousands of years old
oh yeah the Viking sword
the Vikings originating from Scandinavia
rated wide areas of Northern and Central
Europe from the 8th to 11th centuries
the Viking sword was derived from the
Roman spatha and was seen as a matter of
high Prestige and wealth
the large double-edged weapon used in
battle along with the shield often had a
fuller along the length of the blade
increasing the strength and flexibility
while also reducing weight making it
more effective in battle the Hilton
pommel provided balance to the weapon
aiding the swordsman's attack at his
enemy
this iconic weapon has been immortalized
in films like King Arthur
it must be a working version of that
deadly weapon the Vikings said the best
blade was quenched in the piss of a
red-headed virgin I don't know any
red-headed virgins but I imagine oil
will be just fine
good luck blade Smiths we'll see you in
five days good luck good luck man
today is day one of the Viking sword
build and I just want to get my layout
nice your layout's pretty important
there's nothing worse than running
around with a 36 inch piece of really
hot Steel in a on feng shui
environment that kind of rummaged
through the farm scrap yard this is
actually an arm off a chisel plow it's
spring steel tougher than hell
so I figure since I have good steel I'm
not going to do a pattern welded Blade
the strength while it's hot I'm gonna do
something that's going to perform
without the likelihood of failure I
think it just kind of laughs at my
hammer at this point day one I feel good
because essentially I'm figuring out the
tools and so tomorrow put them to use I
have my Steel in the basic shape of the
Viking sword everything's coming in
straight so I'm going to dangle it in
the forage and quench it once
I don't know what's gonna happen here
and I don't know what the forge is going
to do in the vertical position
and I don't know if I can get an even
Heat all right here we go
I don't know even if I'm at the right
temperature
I'm done
pretty straight
still hot
[Music]
it ain't done
but it will kill
I like intentionally breaking stuff not
having stuff break on me so this morning
I'm just gonna do a few tests
[Music]
if anything's gonna happen I'm gonna
find it before the judges do nothing
like testing
[Music]
I'm no longer concerned about my steel
it took quite a bit to break off that
tip so it seems tougher than hell I'm
pretty sure it's going to withstand
anything the judges throw at it
damn it knock on wood
game plan on day one is to make my
Damascus Village
what really sets our blades apart is
going to be the artwork
I figure if I'm going to make it to mask
and sell it I might as well make it
complicated and look nice
I don't know he's got like two guys that
do this
you can actually see the pattern already
this is a mega break moment for any
blood there's always stuff that goes
wrong
that would be it
so I feel really good about how hard my
blade is but I've all really know until
later for sure
nice and tight
let's cut some crap
that sucks
the delamination a little bit seems to
have separated enough got coconut in it
I really need to figure out how to get
these out I think I might have lost my
heat treat from the well
just in case I'm gonna have to re-heat
treat my blade
[Music]
no
thank you
I'm trying to heat treat this with the
handle on but I can't get the blade
itself hot enough it's still flexible
which is not good
salvageable no
should have just left it
and that was my blade
I'm so
just broke my blood
I've got to figure out something and
power through and tearing something in
[Music]
all right gentlemen your weapons will
now be put through a series of three
tests up first is the kill test
Doug
Lane Smiths this is the kill test the
Viking sword was designed to be a
single-handed weapon used to beat you an
enemy's defenses delivering a Thrust a
chop and a slice to test how lethal your
weapon is I would reach you the
simulated sword and then deliver a
Thrust slice and Chop on this ballistics
dummy let's see how much lethal damage
your weapon can do Travis you're up you
ready yep
and he drives his Glade to just fail
otherwise I'm screwed
well Travis you weren't kidding me said
it was a little bit heavy recovery is a
little bit difficult but once you get it
going the sharpness of your Edge
definitely will cleave through anything
in its path if you had a little bit more
weight on the back over here that would
have really definitely counterbalance
the blade but nonetheless
that's a beautiful looking sword
this sir will kill
thank you Morgan you're next you ready
yep
let's do this all right
I was really striving for Perfection so
you take a risk and sometimes it pays
off and sometimes it doesn't
okay uh
Morgan there are a couple of issues that
we have here with your sword
number one
with a handle it's loose
my biggest concern is on your blade
itself not only do I see cracks
I actually see holes in your sword
uh
Morgan due to the issues you have with
your blade for safety reasons we will
not be able to test your sword
that being said though thank you for
sticking with the challenge and
presenting us with a weapon today
gentlemen because we cannot test Morgan
sword we will not move forward with any
other weapons tests
I knew it was coming there was no doubts
about it so I mean it kind of sucks but
you know it is what it is
Morgan Travis you had five days at your
home forges to create your own version
of a Viking sword and you both made
Valiant efforts
Travis congratulations you are the
forged Empire champion
come on man yeah Morgan I'm sorry you
did not make the cut
Morgan you're one of the youngest Smiths
ever to Grace this forage but despite
that you showed so much maturity from
round one where you fell behind and made
it all the way to the finals
Morgan please surrender your weapon
thank you thank you yeah I definitely
agree with the decision you know I
didn't win but it's a pretty good
feeling to know that I can make it this
far and I'm not that little kid in the
backyard tinkering around anymore
Travis congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion and we'll be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars
[Applause]
you got a very very nice looking sword
thank you Travis it's a beautiful bladed
to perform very well this is a health
experience it really tests a person's
ability to adapt Under Fire